To say that JD Vance and Tim Waltz agreed
that a woman should have died seeking an abortion in Georgia,
but that they just disagreed about what killed her,
when JD Vance's entire ideology
and all of the policies that underpin it
are single handed responsible for the laws that killed her,
is preposterous.
The idea that better child care policies and better parental leave,
you know, things that Republicans are so known for fighting for,
would have been able to save her is.
Is so offensive. Is.
It still assumes that JD Vance knows better what you should do
then you do. No,
you don't agree.
And to feign empathy for a woman who died because of your policy
is not civil, it's manipulative.